[Müzik]
Herkese merhabalar ben Meliha Demir
sancak
un derinlerini inelim
şimdi her yerde bir girişimcilik örneği
var İşte o yatırım alıyoruz startuplar
devamında
yatırımlar girişimler linkine
giriyorsunuz Herkes bir CV olmuş böyle
çok farklı bir yapı var her yerde Peki
ne bu girişimcilik dediğimiz
şimdi Bu sorudan da dışarı çıkıp
birazcık kendinizi buradaki 4 tane
vereceğim kelimeye odaklamanızı
istiyorum
bunun hemen Arkasında iki Task görev 3
bulunan çevre bulunan çevre yani Network
4 organizasyon
Aslında teker teker her biri kendi
içinde anlamlı farklı metodolojiler
farklı terimler ama hepsini aldığımız ve
bir ortama koyduğumuzda burada karşımıza
şöyle bir şey çıkıyor Bir ekibiniz var
bunlara bu kişilere bu ekibinize Task
görevlendirmeler yapıyorsunuz yani
dolayısıyla bir organizasyon
oluşturuyorsunuz Aslında ve burada bir
Network oluşturuyorsunuz bir cins Yani
akıllı ekip akıllı yatırımcı ve akıllı
müşteri arasında bir bağlantı
oluşturuyorsunuz
bir de siz gün sonunda bunu müşteri
problemi ile birleştir
diğiniz biz buna tam olarak girişim
cilik yani müşterinin Karşınızdaki
kişinin İlla yani buradaki müşteri
olabilir yatırımcı olabilir ya da
herhangi biri olabilir Bir problemiyle
siz gün sonunda bu 4 tabiri
birleştirdiğinizde karşınıza bir
girişimcilik örneği çıkıyor
şimdi bu logoyu herkes biliyor Neyi
logosu bu
zaten biliyoruz Samsung Şimdi şöyle bir
düşünmenizi istiyorum Acaba bunların
toplamı birazcık matematik üzerinden
vesaire gideceğiz bunların toplamı nedir
birazcık bunu
düşünelim Şimdi bazılarınız şunu
düşünebilir bu iki şirket birleşse Ne
olacak şimdi tam olarak Aslında ben bu
kitleyi istiyorum bunu düşünmenizi
istiyorum şimdi bunların toplamı
arkadaşlar Türkiye diyor
şimdi gün sonunda sermaye toplamlarından
bahsediyorum yani bir gün Deseler ki ya
Türkiye bize tak etti birleşip bizi
satın alabilirler
Rusça 20 milyar dolarlık Plus bir
yatırım da yapabilirler yani şu an bir
köprü daha yapabilirler bunun gibi bir
örnek içerisindeyiz Aslında ne demeye
çalışıyorum nereye getirmeye çalışıyorum
konuyu
ya siyasetinden ülkelerin siyasetinden
çıkararak şu anda bir ekonomi modüle
oluşturduk ve şirketlerin siyasetinden
bahsediyorsun şirketlerin siyaseti
Burada o kadar büyük startuplar büyük
şirketler var ki dünyadaki büyük bir
değerimiz sermayesine Gayri safi milli
hasılatına
mevcutap edebilen şirketler sermayeleri
ile
atacağız dünya demişken iklim
değişikliğini herkes biliyordur
son dönem en büyük problemlerinden biri
ve şu anda hepimizi yavaş yavaş ölüme
sürükleyen bir konu
417 ppm karbondioksitten bahsediyoruz
artan bir karbondioksit Yani bizi
boğuyor diğer tarafta bir nokta sıfır
bir Yani bir buçuk derecelik ısınmaya
son 0.49'luk bir
içerisine bir yüksek bir ivme içerisine
girdik ve son olarak şu ana kadar
3.94 inç artmış bir deniz seviyesinden
bahsediyoruz
görmek istiyorum size
Bu sayı size ne ifade ediyor var mı
tahminler alalım şöyle
Evet yok galiba Arkadaşlar ben bu
sayıyla lisede tanıştım lise 12 milyon
600 Bu sayı Bu arada 8 milyonlardaydı
geçen senenin verilerine göre 12 milyon
600 Arkadaşlar bir sene içerisinde Dünya
üzerinde
çevre kirliliğinden ölen insan sayısı
bakın
Korona gibi bir illetten geçtik daha
doğrusu hala içindeyiz hala bir
tehlikedeyiz koronadan toplamda
6.28 milyon insanımız öldü
Ama her sene artan bir rakamla 12 milyon
600 bin insanımız şu anda hayatını
kaybediyor ve kimse ama kimse sesini
çıkarmıyor halde diye bağırıyorsun
ebaya bağlıyoruz
itti bakanlıklarına çevre bakanlıklarına
bağlıyorsun ama
Çünkü Mevcut durumda işin ucunda para
var Eğer duyarsak
Ben aslında lisede tanıştım demiştim
Benim Hikayem lisede başlıyor
girişimcilik hikaye Ben kimim birazdan
onu geleceğim ben bir kademe Sancak bir
teknoloj
[Müzik]
i gibi Ve ayrıca bir mühendisim
lisede
lisenin başlarından
çevrecilik temalı işlerde buralarda
bizzat aktivist olarak yer aldım ve
iklim değişikliği ile ilgili çok teknik
bilgiler burada edindim Mevcut durumda
Kendimi geliştirdim lise Sonlara doğru
kendimi
çevre bilimi konusunda çevre
mühendisliği konusunda bir Atılım
Aslında içerisine soktu ve Gebze Teknik
Üniversitesi Çevre mühendisliğine yazdım
ve girdim burada çok değerli hocalarımla
çalıştım
bölümümüzde çok değerli hocalarımız var
onlarla çalıştım bir araştırma yazısı
ortaya çıkardım ve Araştırma yazısından
sonra aslında benim hayatımın en kritik
ve o kırılım noktası dediğimiz var ya
Burayı
ve 2.000 point ne ulaştı Ben harvard'dan
iklim değişikliği konusunda bir uzmanlık
almıştım aslında bir tane hoca bana
ulaştı
dedi ki birkancım araştırma yazısını
okuduk ilgili biliyoruz hocalarla
konuştuk Sen gel biz senin bölümün
içerisine koyalım ve burada bir uzmanlık
al işte benim Hayatım burada başladı
çevre teknolojileri ile ve arka tarafta
insanların üzerindeki 12 milyon 600 bin
sayısını aşağı çekmek ile ilgili o
günden itibaren çalışmalarıma başladı
üniversiteye geçmiştim çalışmalarımı
yapıyordum Bu sırada
daha karşılaştım bir tabirle
çok arıyoruz burada
Steve Jobs ile tanıştım onun
girişimcilik macerasını öğrendim arka
tarafta iklim değişik
liği plan var işte girişimcilik demin
neydi bir müşteri problemi var bir
problem var Ve ayrıca bir de bizim 4
tane temel ilkemiz var Bunları
birleştirerek kendim Start dünyasına
girişimci dünyasına atılmaya başladı ilk
şirketi mi Türkiye'de kurdum
ve ardından Amerika'ya taşıdım
Amerika'da San francisco'da silikon
vadisinde görevler aldım Burada bizzat
hem kofandur hem fanus hem de Ceo
rolünde çalışmalar gerçekleştirdim bu
çalışmalarım sırasında
inceliğe hem yakından hem de bizzat
silikon Vadisinin içinden görme şansım
ve oradaki girişimcilerle yaşama şansım
oldu
ilk şirketimi 176 milyon dolarlık bir
değerleme ile sattım ve sonrasında
Türkiye'ye geri geldim o sırada bu arada
hala okuyorum arkadaşlar
Aslında genç bir girişimciyim Yani
sizden çok çok büyük değilim ama büyüğüm
öyle değil yani lise çağındaki
öğrenciler
şimdi
problemle karşılaştım bu problemde hava
kalitesinin nasıl ölçümlendiğini
kurarak drone kamera teknoloji ile hava
kalitesi ve baca gazı incelemeleri
konusunda yani
genel iklim değişikliğinin
olumlu yönde etkilenmesi konusunda
insanlık yararı etkilenmesi konusunda
çalışmalarını gerçekleştiriyoruz
peki Ben şu an neredeyim bir girişimci
olarak nasılsın Tekin kofan'dır ve ctosu
var arkadaşlar yani bunca başarı 2 tane
exit ya da üçüncü İnşallah exit Mevcut
durumda gelmiyor illaki bir yerlerde bir
batış hikayeleri arıyorsunuz O da başka
bir tedx konusu olsun iki eksiktin var
arkadaşlar ve şu anda 30'dan fazla da
startup yatırımını gerçekleştirdim ve
büyümeye de her gün devam ediyoruz 4
tane
şirketinden fazla dinleyicisi olan bir
podcastin sahibiyim Podcast kanalına
sahibim
içerikler üretiyor Peki beni bu noktaya
getiren Ne oldu yani en başta
biliyorsunuz en bahsettik birazcık
kişisel eğitim
den var burada Öncelikle kitaplar şimdi
her tedx'teki gibi şunu okuyun İşte şu
tavsiye vereyim gibisinden bir şeyler
söylemeyeceğim Ama ben burada genel
kitaplar diyeceğim yani sonuçta kitabı
ben şöyle görüyorum geçmişle bağlantı
kurduğunuz bir kapı Bu da çok önemli bir
şey ve Bence en önemli en değerli
kaynaklarımızdan birisi diğeri benim
kelamdır Bunu dün ss'ini aldım
screenshot'unu aldım buraya koydum
Bayağı kalabalık bir kağıdıdır bunu
kullanıyorum ve bir de Network
geliştiksel gelişim için kitaplar
ve ayrıca Network işte
bu ünü ben yapan anonim
öğrendim Mesela ne aktarmaya çalışıyorum
arkadaşlar girişimci doğmazsın
Sen ne kadar çevrene Bu konuyla ilgili
geliştirirsen yani odağını ne kadar
girişimciliğe verirsen mevcut
o kadar başarılı olursun bu konuda
ve bu
olur Bu tamamen eğitimle ilgilidir örnek
verecek olursam
Harvard
iş kanundaki şu kadar milyar dolar
değerleme şu kadar milyon dolar
değerleme diye aralarında savaşıyorlar
Düşünsenize adam Yani şu anda o iki
üniversiteden çıkan şirketlerin bu kadar
büyük değerler yaratması arkasında
illaki bir doğru eğitimi bir parçası
diyebiliriz Peki kendimizin nasıl
eğiteceğiz nasıl bir Aslında süreç
içerisinde sokmamız gerekiyor burada
Mevcut durumda 3 tane kapımız var
arkadaşlar bir okul iki hızlandırıcılar
Yani bir girişimci olarak
aksederatörlerin içerisinde bulunmak
Birsel eğitim Mevcut durumda okul iki
tane probleme sahip
eğitimlerde eğitimlere geçtik şu anda
okulda ne yazık ki bir giriş
imcilik ve ayrıca girişimciler burada
sunumda
içi sınav kültürü var içeride bir ders
kültürü var Evet Bunlar olmasın
demiyorum ama
girişimcilik ruhunu etkileyecek biçimde
yani daha doğrusu ekonomik kalkınmayı
doğru şekilde doğru yönde etkileyecek
biçimde bizim bunları evrilmemiz
gerekiyor burada derslere bakıyoruz
ülkede verilen derslere bir mühendis
gerçekten tamamen bir mühendis gibi
yetişiyor Okey bunda bir problemi yok
ama bir mühendis bir sınıftan anlamıyor
Eğer işin içine girmedikçe ya da Bizans
okuyan biri işletme okuyan biri hiçbir
şekilde teknik tarafa hem Yiğit edemiyor
eğer içinde bulunmadıysa
problemlerle karşılaş
ıyor Bu yüzden
bu harmanlayıp
çıkarmamız ülkece ve dünyaca gerekiyor
Burada tabii arka tarafta söndürülüyor
dedim sınav kültürü dedim Mevcut durumda
Biz burada eğitimler sırasında
öğrencilerimizi sürekli olarak sıkıp
sürekli olarak bu
gerilimden uzağa taşıyoruz Bu da bizim
aslında istemediğimiz bir konu
hızlandırıcılar ülkemizde belli başlı
aksesuarlar var çok başarılılar çok
güzeller çok değer katıyorlar fakat
Mevcut durumda sadece dünya
literatüründen aldıkları eğitimleri
veriyorlar Bu eğitimlerle girişimcileri
bir yere getirmemiz onlarla konuşmamız
ve Aslında girişimcilik görmesini en
sonunda vereceğim ama bir problemi
tespit edip bunu bir adım sonraya
geçirmemiz
çok çok önemli bir eğitim Aslında bu
örneği oluşturmak yerine sürekli olarak
Klişe eğitimler veriyoruz bunları bir
kenara koyup gerçekten full Odak
müşteriye
ve iskelet etme aşamasına yani Büyütme
aşamasına
sonra burada kendi kişisel eğitimin
üzerinde bahsettim Mevcut durumda ben
neler yaptım kitap okudum dedim planlı
oldum ve Network ama arkadaşlar benim
bir sırrım var hepinize
bu durumda sokağa indi Başka işi
yapmanıza gerek yok Sokak
insanlarla Konuşun esnafla konuşun
müşterinizle konuşun bakın Evet
farkındayım şu anda ülkemizde büyük bir
Ön yargı var İlk defa birine
yaklaşıyorsunuz konuşuyorsunuz
ediyorsunuz ama arkadaşlar konuşmaya
açık olan çok daha değerli ve çok daha
bilgi sahibi olan ve bunu açık olan
insanlar var onları bulup onlarla
konuşun onları problemlerini tespit edin
Örneğin Geçen gün metroda ilerliyorum
Taksim'e mi gidiyordum
bir problemle problemi olan bir müşteri
Aslında müşteri portföyü orada şununla
karşılaştım
bunun da ondan birkaç tane
ve o bilenliğine karşı bir ürün
oluşturabilir miyim
bunu Bu arkadaşlar insanlarla konuşmak
ve onların Dertlerine anlayabilmek
sokağa indim
yaklaşıyoruz ama Mevcut durumda
artık birileri yok
kaybediyoruz bugünün ana teması
kaybediyoruz
ama erkek Lisesi'nden 152.6
Mevcut durumda Alman lisesinden 94 7
Galatasaray'dan da 32 altılık
buradaki öğrencilerin hepsini biz
yurtdışı göndermiyoruz kendileri
gidiyorlar Peki kendileri neden
gidiyorlar Neden biz bunları bu kişilere
bu değerli cinsleri ülkemizde
barındıramıyoruz bunun üzerine benim
Takip ettiğim ve araştırmalarına Hayran
Olduğum bir kişi var Evrim Kuran buradan
kendisine de selam olsun
Kendisi çok güzel bir araştırma yapmış
ve demiş ki gençler neden gidiyor Çok
güzel listelemiş
üç sebepler
üçünü okuyacağım ülkenin siyasi iklimi
ve iş olanaklarının yetersizliği
arkadaşlar
birçoğu da aklın
yetersizlik zaten peşinde
durumdaki Yani iş bulma konusundaki
yetersizlikleri getiriyor İşte bizim
bunun önüne geçmek için bir girişimcilik
adamına ihtiyacımız var bu kayıpları
engelleyebilmemiz için
elimizden kalkıp bir hareket etmeye
ihtiyacımız var
her zaman vurgul
adığım Hem her pod kestim de hem de
bugün siz Tenek üyeleri ile bahsetmem
gibi müşterinizle konuşun ona ulaşıp ve
onu işim haline geçin
değiştirin Yani ben müşterimin
problemine nasıl bir çare bulabilirim
bunu düşünün
diye bir tane çözüm modeli podcasti
çektim en son
yani gidin ve müşterinizle bunu konuşun
bunun bu çözümünüzün üzerine bir atak
yapın ve son olarak da Global etki
yoluna adım atın ki ülkemizden bu
kayıplar yaşanmasın ve ülkemiz hem
girişimcilik hem de startup anlamında
değilsin hepinize teşekkür ederim
[Müzik]
[Alkış]